two years ago almost to the day actually
I put up the first video on this channel
about Euler's formula e to the PI I
equals negative one as an anniversary of
sorts I want to revisit that same idea
for one thing I've always kind of wanted
to improve on the presentation but I
wouldn't rehash an old topic if there
wasn't something new to teach you see
the idea underlying that video was to
take certain concepts from a field of
math called group theory and show how
they give Oilers formula a much richer
interpretation than a mere association
between numbers and two years ago I
thought it might be fun to use those
ideas without referencing group theory
itself or any of the technical terms
within it but I've come to see that you
all actually quite like getting into the
math itself even if it takes some time
so here two years later lets you and me
go through an introduction to the basics
of group theory building up to how
Euler's formula comes to life under this
light if all you want is a quick
explanation of Euler's formula and if
you're comfortable with vector calculus
I'll go ahead and put up a particularly
short explanation on the screen that you
can pause and ponder on if it doesn't
make sense don't worry about it it's not
needed for where we're going the reason
that I want to put out this group Theory
view though is not because I think it's
a better explanation heck it's not even
a complete proof it's just an intuition
really it's because it has the chance to
change how you think about numbers and
how you think about algebra you see
group theory is all about studying the
nature of symmetry for example a square
is a very symmetric shape but what do we
actually mean by that one way to answer
that is to ask you about what are all
the actions you can take on the square
that leave it looking indistinguishable
from how it started for example you
could rotate it 90 degrees
counterclockwise and it looks totally
the same to how it started
you could also flip it around this
vertical line and again it still looks
identical in fact the thing about such
perfect symmetry is that it's hard to
keep track of what action has actually
been taken so to help out I'm going to
go ahead and stick on an asymmetric
image here
now we call each one of these actions a
symmetry of the square and all of the
symmetries together make up a group of
symmetries or just group for short this
particular group consists of eight
symmetries there's the action of doing
nothing which is one that we count plus
three different rotations and then those
four ways that you can flip it over and
in fact this group of eight symmetries
has a special name it's called the
dihedral group of order eight and that's
an example of a finite group consisting
of only eight actions but a lot of other
groups consist of infinitely many
actions think of all possible rotations
for example of any angle maybe you think
of this as a group that acts on a circle
capturing all of the symmetries of that
circle that don't involve flipping it
here every action from this group of
rotation lies somewhere on the infinite
continuum between zero and two pi
radians one nice aspect of these actions
is that we can associate each one of
them with a single point on the circle
itself the thing being acted on you
start by choosing some arbitrary point
maybe the one on the right here then
every circle symmetry every possible
rotation takes this marked point to some
unique spot on the circle and the action
itself is completely determined by where
it takes that spot now this doesn't
always happen with groups but it's nice
when it does happen because it gives us
a way to label the actions themselves
which can otherwise be pretty tricky to
think about the study of groups is not
just about what a particular set of
symmetries is whether that's the eight
symmetries of a square the infinite
continuum of symmetries of the circle or
anything else you dream up the real
heart and soul of the study is knowing
how these symmetries play with each
other on the square if I rotate 90
degrees and then flip around the
vertical axis
the overall effect is the same as if I
had just flipped over this diagonal line
so in some sense that rotation plus the
vertical flip equals that diagonal flip
on the circle if I rotate 270 degrees
and then follow it with a rotation of
120 degrees the overall effect is the
same as if I had just rotated 30 degrees
to start with so in this circle group a
270 degree rotation plus a 120 degree
rotation equals a 30 degree rotation and
in general with any group any collection
of these sorts of symmetric actions
there's a kind of arithmetic where you
can always take two actions and add them
together to get a third one by applying
one after the other or maybe you think
of it as multiplying actions it doesn't
really matter the point is that there is
some way to combine the two actions to
get out another one that collection of
underlying relations all associations
between pairs of actions and the single
action that's equivalent to applying one
after the other that's really what makes
a group a group it's actually crazy how
much of modern math is rooted in in well
this in understanding how a collection
of actions is organized by this relation
this relation between pairs of actions
and the single action you get by
composing that groups are extremely
general a lot of different ideas can be
framed in terms of symmetries and
composing symmetries and maybe the most
familiar example is numbers just
ordinary numbers and there are actually
two separate ways to think about numbers
as a group one where composing actions
is going to look like addition and
another where composing actions will
look like multiplication it's a little
weird because we don't usually think of
numbers as actions we usually think of
them as counting things but let me show
you what I mean think of all of the ways
that you can slide a number line left or
right along itself this collection of
all sliding actions
is a group well you might think of as
the group of symmetries on an infinite
line and in the same way that actions
from the circle group could be
associated with individual points on
that circle this is another one of those
special groups where we can associate
each action with a unique point on the
thing that it's actually acting on you
just follow where the point that starts
at zero ends up for example the number
three is associated with the action of
sliding right by three units the number
negative two is associated with the
action of sliding two units to the left
since that's the unique action that
drags the point at zero over to the
point at negative two the number zero
itself
well that's associated with the action
of just doing nothing this group of
sliding actions each one of which is
associated with a unique real number has
a special name the additive group of
real numbers the reason the word
additive is in there is because of what
the group operation of applying one
action followed by another looks like if
I slide right by three units and then I
slide right by two units the overall
effect is the same as if I slid right by
three plus two or five units simple
enough we're just adding the distances
of each slide but the point here is that
this gives an alternate view for what
numbers even are they are one example in
a much larger category of groups groups
of symmetries acting on some object and
the arithmetic of adding numbers is just
one example of the arithmetic that any
group of symmetries has within it we
could also extend this idea instead
asking about the sliding actions on the
complex plane the newly introduced
numbers I 2 I 3 I and so on on this
vertical line would all be associated
with vertical sliding motions since
those are the actions that drag the
point at 0 up to the relevant point on
that vertical line
the point over here at 3+2 I would be
associated with the action of sliding
the plane in such a way that drags zero
up and to the right to that point and it
should make sense why we call this 3 + 2
I that diagonal sliding action is the
same as first sliding by three to the
right and then following it with a slide
that corresponds to two I which is two
units vertically similarly let's get a
feel for how composing any two of these
actions generally breaks down consider
this slide by 3 + 2 I action as well as
this slide by 1 minus 3 I action and
imagine applying one of them right after
the other
the overall effect the composition of
these two sliding actions is the same as
if we had slid 3 + 1 to the right and 2
minus 3 vertically notice how that
involves adding together each component
so composing sliding actions is another
way to think about what adding complex
numbers actually means this collection
of all sliding actions on the 2d complex
plane goes by the name the additive
group of complex numbers again the
upshot here is that numbers even complex
numbers are just one example of a group
and the idea of addition can be thought
of in terms of successively applying
actions but numbers schizophrenic as
they are also lead a completely
different life as a completely different
kind of group consider a new group of
actions on the number line always that
you can stretch or squish it keeping
everything evenly spaced and keeping
that number 0 fixed in place yet again
this group of actions has that nice
property where we can associate each
action in the group with a specific
point on the thing that it's acting on
in this case follow where the point that
starts at the number one goes there is
one and only one stretching action that
brings that point at one - the point at
3 for instance namely stretching by a
factor of 3 likewise there is one and
only one action that brings that point
at one - the point at one half
namely squishing by a factor of 1/2 I
like to imagine using one hand to fix
the number 0 in place and using the
other to drag the number 1 wherever I
like while the rest of the number line
just does whatever it takes to stay
evenly spaced in this way every single
positive number is associated with a
unique stretching or squishing action
now notice what composing actions looks
like in this group if I apply the
stretch by 3 action and then follow it
with the stretch by 2 action the overall
effect is the same as if I had just
applied the stretch by 6 action the
product of the two original numbers and
in general applying one of these actions
followed by another corresponds with
multiplying the numbers that they are
associated with in fact the name for
this group is the multiplicative group
of positive real numbers so
multiplication ordinary familiar
multiplication is one more example of
this very general and very far-reaching
idea of groups and the arithmetic within
groups and we can also extend this idea
to the complex plane again I like to
think of fixing 0 in place with one hand
and dragging around the point at 1
keeping everything else evenly spaced
while I do so but this time as we drag
the number 1 to places that are off the
real number line we see that our group
includes not only stretching and
squishing actions but actions that have
some rotational component as well the
quintessential example of this is the
action associated with that point at I 1
unit above 0 what it takes to drag the
point at 1 to that point at I is a 90
degree rotation so the multiplicative
action associated with I is a 90 degree
rotation and notice if I apply that
action twice in a row the overall effect
is to flip the plane 180 degrees and
that is the unique action that brings
the point at 1 over 2 negative 1
so in this sense I times I equals
negative one meaning the action
associated with I followed by that same
action associated with I has the same
overall effect as the action associated
with negative one as another example
here's the action associated with two
plus I dragging one up to that point if
you want you could think of this as
broken down as a rotation by 30 degrees
followed by a stretch by a factor of
square root of five and in general every
one of these multiplicative actions is
some combination of a stretch or a
squish an action associated with some
point on the positive real number line
followed by a pure rotation where pure
rotations are associated with points on
this circle the one with radius one this
is very similar to how the sliding
actions in the additive group could be
broken down as some pure horizontal
slide represented with points on the
real number line plus some purely
vertical slide represented with points
on that vertical line that comparison of
how actions in each group breaks down is
going to be important so remember it in
each one you can break down any action
as some purely real number action
followed by something that's specific to
complex numbers whether that's vertical
slides for the additive group or pure
rotations for the multiplicative group
so that's our quick introduction to
groups a group is a collection of
symmetric actions on some mathematical
object whether that's a square a circle
the real number line or anything else
you dream up and every group has a
certain arithmetic where you can combine
two actions by applying one after the
other and asking what other action from
the group gives the same overall effect
numbers both real and complex numbers
can be thought of in two different ways
as a group they can act by sliding in
which case the group arithmetic just
looks like ordinary addition
or they can act by these stretching
squishing rotating actions in which case
the group arithmetic looks just like
multiplication and with that let's talk
about exponentiation our first
introduction to exponents is to think of
them in terms of repeated multiplication
right I mean the meaning of something
like 2 cubed is to take 2 times 2 times
2 and the meaning of something like 2 to
the fifth is 2 times 2 times 2 times 2
times 2 and a consequence of this
something you might call the exponential
property is that if I add two numbers in
the exponent say 2 to the 3 plus 5 this
can be broken down as the product of 2
to the 3rd times 2 to the 5 and when you
expand things this seems reasonable
enough right but expressions like 2 to
the 1/2 or 2 to the negative 1 and much
less 2 to the I don't really make sense
when you think of exponents as repeated
multiplication I mean what does it mean
to multiply 2 by itself half of a time
or negative 1 of a time so we do
something very common throughout math
and extend beyond the original
definition which only makes sense for
counting numbers to something that
applies to all sorts of numbers but we
don't just do this randomly if you think
back to how fractional and negative
exponents are defined it's always
motivated by trying to make sure that
this property 2 to the X plus y equals 2
to the x times 2 to the Y still holds to
see what this might mean for complex
exponents think about what this property
is saying from a group theory light it's
saying that adding the inputs
corresponds with multiplying the outputs
and that makes it very tempting to think
of the inputs not merely as numbers but
as members of the additive group of
sliding actions and to think of the
outputs not merely as numbers but as
members of this multiplicative group of
stretching and squashing actions
now it is weird and strange to think
about functions that take in one kind of
action and spit out another kind of
action but this is something that
actually comes up all the time
throughout group theory and this
exponential property is very important
for this association between groups it
guarantees that if I compose two sliding
actions maybe a slide by negative one
and then a slide by positive two it
corresponds to composing the two output
actions in this case
squishing by two to the negative one and
then stretching by two squared
mathematicians would describe a property
like this by saying that the function
preserves the group structure in the
sense that the arithmetic within a group
is what gives it its structure and a
function like this exponential plays
nicely with that arithmetic functions
between groups that preserve the
arithmetic like this are really
important throughout group theory enough
so that they've earned themselves a nice
fancy named homomorphisms
now think about what all of this means
for associating the additive group in
the complex plane with the
multiplicative group in the complex
plane we already know that when you plug
in a real number to 2 to the X you get
out a real number a positive real number
in fact so this exponential function
takes any purely horizontal slide and
turns it into some pure stretching or
squishing action so wouldn't you agree
that it would be reasonable for this new
dimension of additive actions slides up
and down to map directly into this new
dimension of multiplicative actions pure
rotations those vertical sliding actions
correspond to points on this vertical
axis and those rotating multiplicative
actions correspond to points on the
circle with radius 1 so what it would
mean for an exponential function like 2
to the X 2 map purely vertical slides
into pure rotations would be the complex
numbers on this vertical line multiples
of I get mapped to
complex numbers on this unit circle in
fact for the function two to the X the
input I a vertical slide of one unit
happens to map to a rotation of about
0.693 radians that is a walk around the
unit circle that covers 0.693 units of
distance with a different exponential
function say 5 to the X that input I a
vertical slide of one unit would map to
a rotation of about one point six zero
nine radians a walk around the unit
circle covering exactly one point six
zero nine units of distance what makes
the number E special is that when the
exponential e to the X maps vertical
slides two rotations in a vertical slide
of one unit corresponding to I maps to a
rotation of exactly one Radian a walk
around the unit circle covering a
distance of exactly one and so a
vertical slide of two units would map to
a rotation of two radians a three unit
slide up corresponds to a rotation of
three radians and a vertical slide of
exactly pi units up corresponding to the
input pi x i maps to a rotation of
exactly pi radians halfway around the
circle and that's the multiplicative
action associated with the number
negative one now you might ask why e why
not some other base well the full answer
resides in calculus I mean that's the
birthplace of E and where it's even
defined again I'll leave up another
explanation on the screen if you're
hungry for a fuller description and if
you're comfortable with the calculus but
at a high level I'll say that it has to
do with the fact that all exponential
functions are proportional to their own
derivative but e to the X alone is the
one that's actually equal to its own
derivative the important point that I
want to make here though is that if you
view things from the lens of group
Theory thinking of the inputs to an
exponential function as sliding actions
and thinking of the outputs as
stretching and rotating actions
gives a very vivid way to read what a
formula like this is even saying when
you read it you can think that
Exponential's in general map purely
vertical slides the additive actions
that are perpendicular to the real
number line into pure rotations which
are in some sense perpendicular to the
real number stretching actions and
moreover e to the X does this in the
very special way that ensures that a
vertical slide of pi units corresponds
to a rotation of exactly pi radians the
180-degree rotation associated with the
number negative one to finish things off
here I want to show a way that you can
think about this function e to the X as
a transformation of the complex plane
but before that just two quick messages
I've mentioned before just how thankful
I am to you the community for making
these videos possible through patreon
but in much the same way that numbers
become more meaningful when you think of
them as actions gratitude is also best
expressed as an action so I've decided
to turn off ads on new videos for their
first month in the hopes of giving you
all a better viewing experience this
video was sponsored by Emerald cloud lab
and actually I was the one to reach out
to them on this one
since it's a company I find particularly
inspiring emerald is a very unusual
start-up half software half biotech the
cloud lab that they're building
essentially enables biologists and
chemists to conduct research through a
software platform instead of working in
a lab scientists can program experiments
which are then executed remotely and
robotically in Emerald's industrialized
research lab I know some of the people
at the company and the software
challenges they're working on are really
interesting currently they're looking to
hire software engineers and web
developers for their engineering team as
well as applied mathematicians and
computer scientists for their scientific
computing team
if you're interested in applying whether
that's now or a few months from now
there are a couple special links in the
description of this video and if you
apply through those it lets emerald know
that you heard about them through this
channel alright so e to the X
transforming the plane I like to imagine
first rolling that plane into a cylinder
wrapping all those vertical lines into
circles and then taking that cylinder
and kind of smashing it on to the plane
around zero where each of those
concentric circles spaced out
exponentially correspond with what
started off as vertical lines
[Music]
[Music]